Okay, so I'm looking here to
see if I have any errors.
It looks like I forgot braces here for
dequeue.
So I'm calling that
method correctly now.
So now I'm just going to go ahead and
go through my test cases
that I mentioned before.
I'm just going to put them
in this little box here and
we had our None, our empty brackets.
So we go through these,
zero returns zero immediately, so
that's working, and what about when
we actually have a working test case?
That goes through most
of this code here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so I go through,
so that one's a 0.
Checking the length.
So, this would be set to 3.
And this would be 2.
So, going through every element.
So, I find my first one.
I'm incrementing my island count, so
now that's going to be equal to one.
And I got my FindPartsOfIsland method
here, creating my q, appending those
values and then I have my breadth first
search here that I'm going through.
And so for this instance, there is no
one to the right or on the bottom of it,
so I won't have to do this,
and then I go to the next one.
Sent zero, so we don't do anything,
we just go through the loop.
One, okay, so
I'm going to increment my island
count again it's now going to be two.
So then I go through that and
then I find my parts of island,
so there actually are ones here, so
I'm going to go ahead and
add those, then I add those there.
And that looks all good,
and so this one,
this one actually get set to 2 there.
And this is going to get set to 2 and
now I'm adding both of these
to the queue to look at them.
And we're not appending
any this up front,
I'm only appending that to the queue.
So I'm looking through there,
there's nothing else and so
basically it's going to be setting
these to 2, and that's, and
then I'd probably just visit
every element in the array.
There's no more ones, so
that would be end of it.
But it looks like I forgot to
return the number of islands here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So it looks like it works.
Well it looks like all
of his code worked.
Not only is this fellow handsome but
he sure is intelligent.
>> The debugging process
is often overlooked but
a very important part of
the algorithm interview.
Not only does this show the interviewer
that the candidate checks their code,
it may even help the candidate find
mistakes that they missed the first
time they were coding their solution.
It's easy to miss a semicolon here and
there if a candidate were coding in some
language like Java, or
forget to return a result.